foreign
you guys finally getting back to doing
another flickers of fear like I said
sorry these are kind of few and far
between but you know life's kind of busy
at the moment but I am still trying to
get these out now this movie I was so
you don't even know you don't even know
how excited I was like to come across
this movie when I was scrolling through
HBO Max uh so as of this recording I
believe it's still an HBO Max and I
think they just added it not too long
ago so I was super jazzed uh to see this
on there because I haven't seen it in
such a long time
so Danny Boyle the British director uh
I'm sure most of you will be familiar
with him now I think that he probably
first came to kind of like International
prominence roundabout 1996 which is when
Trainspotting came out which was like
his big breakout hit obviously uh you
know his kind of scuzzy black comedy
about drug addicts which is still like a
super fun movie today and I think at the
time the movie was kind of largely
credited with sort of revitalizing the
British film industry at the time which
I feel like had been a little stagnant
not necessarily in the quality of the
films necessarily but just in the sense
that I guess British cinema at the time
was kind of more known for doing like
you know very prestigious like period
pieces or social realism dramas some you
know that kind of thing so this movie
when it came out was kind of like a shot
in the arm and like I kind of feel like
it was sort of the precursor of all
those 90s and 2000s like British crime
Thrillers and stuff like that that you
know that people loved so much so this
was kind of like the start of that
now uh obviously Danny Boyle would go on
to much greater Acclaim and you know
success around the world 28 Days Later
obviously great film Sunshine uh Slumdog
Millionaire he got an Oscar for that uh
127 Hours the one about the guy that had
to saw his arm off you know all that
kind of stuff so he made like a ton
of movies before all that though
back in 1994 Danny Boyle's debut feature
film I feel like it also kind of made
waves at least in the UK or at least in
Europe he because he actually did get a
bafta for it and several other Awards
like across Europe
um and it was also the most successfully
like the most commercially successful
film of that year like in the UK uh that
movie was shallow grave which is
actually kind of like a black comedy
crime Thriller about a group of horrible
friends and sort of the depths that they
sink to in order to get their hands or
rather keep their hands on like this big
heap of money
um not only did shallow grave kind of
set the stage I guess for Danny Boyle's
sort of meteoric Rise Like I said it
kind of he went right from that like
into doing Trainspotting which got him
like famous around the world it also I
have to say served as something of like
a star making vehicle for
who at the time like two of the UK's
kind of most exciting and upcoming young
actors which we will get into in a
little bit
so shallow grave was actually written by
a dude named John Hodge who was actually
a doctor uh this was his first produced
screenplay and one that would lead to
several more collaborations with Danny
Boyle going forward I believe he also
adapted uh Trainspotting from the novel
as well now shallow grave this was a
movie that I only saw like a few years
after it came out like I had already
seen Trainspotting and I really liked it
so I was going back and I was you know
kind of going back and forth to Britain
a lot of time when I was married to a
British person at the time and he
recommended shallow grave to me because
it was Danny Boyle's first movie so for
whatever reason it just didn't get as
famous or as culturally relevant as
Trainspotting did like a couple years
later
um but as soon as I saw it on DVD like
maybe in 97 or 98 or something like that
I just really kind of like fell in love
with it so it also kind of it it always
makes me kind of sad that it's not sort
of like better known I guess at least in
my perception I feel like a lot of
people don't really talk about it and
that's kind of a shame because this is
actually like a pretty great movie like
especially if you like Trainspotting you
can see a lot of Danny Boyle's like
stylistic
um you know elements like coming through
like very early on in this movie so at
the center of the story you have three
flatmates who are all kind of like young
professionals like as like middle class
upper middle class first you have a
doctor Dr Juliet Miller and she is
played by Carrie Fox and actually it's
kind of ironic like you know considering
how famous the other two guys got later
on but she was kind of like the big draw
at the time like the big get uh for this
movie because she was kind of like an
indie sweetheart at the time I believe
she'd been in a Jane Campion movie and
stuff like that so they were like really
jazzed to get her um so her character is
kind of like this very cold sort of like
flirtatious woman and they don't really
say anything about it and it doesn't
really go anywhere but it just kind of
like informs her character that like the
telephone and the flat is like always
ringing
um and it's like supposedly like for her
but she never wants to answer it so it
kind of like hints at all of these sort
of like romantic entanglements that are
going on in the background
then you have this kind of squirrely
chartered accountant whose name is David
Stevens uh he's actually played by
Christopher Eccleston who's actually one
of my favorite actors
um and this was one of his early film
roles I feel like most people know him
like from his stint on Doctor Who
although I got really into him from just
seeing him in a lot of British films I
loved him in Jude which if you haven't
seen it is really good um based on the
very depressing Thomas Hardy novel Jude
the Obscure Tate Winslet is in that too
I think I haven't seen that for a while
but I actually really love that movie
but it is like a bummer but yeah
Christopher eccleson is in that too
so his character he's an accountant so
he's very
in a retentive he's like really uptight
like really nervous really introverted
uh you know that kind of thing and then
you have a tabloid journalist by the
name of Alex law who was played by the
then nearly unknown Ewan McGregor I
believe this was only his second film
role in his first kind of like leading
film role the previous one that he'd
done he was like more of a minor
character but yeah so this was kind of
his big breakout role so Alex is kind of
like the Wise Acre of the group I guess
like he's very mouthy he's very flippant
he's very casually cruel
um and he's really doesn't take anything
at all seriously like I said he's always
like why is cracking like and it's
usually like mean-spirited
so the three of these these three people
they share this really huge flat in you
know what you're presuming is a very
desirable neighborhood of Edinburgh
Scotland even though the whole thing
most of it was shot in Glasgow but it's
supposed to be Edinburgh so you know
what I mean whatever close enough you
know it's the same country at least it's
interesting because the dynamic between
these three people is
pretty it is pretty fascinating like
from the get-go like they all even
though their personalities are like
wildly different they all kind of share
this particular sort of I guess very
youthful arrogance they're all like late
20s early 30s type of thing
um they kind of have a lack of
compassion for others
um and sort of Revel in their I guess
middle class privilege and their you
know perceived superiority like over
other people I guess there's also this
kind of unspoken but pretty obvious
sexual tension between like all three of
them
um Juliet and Alex are constantly
flirting there's a hint that maybe they
had something going on in the past
although this is never really explored
um David the accountant he kind of seems
to quietly Pine for Juliet from the
sidelines but sort of like stays on the
outside of it and Juliet like for her
part because of the way that her
character is she kind of seems to take
sort of special maybe like narcissistic
Delight in being objective desire for
these two guys who she knows are never
gonna get in her pants you know what I
mean so at the very beginning of the
movie
um the flatmates are looking for a
fourth person like to share their large
apartment now it's never really
particularly made clear why they need a
fourth tenant I mean they look like
they're doing okay financially or if
they even had a fourth flatmate before
uh and if they did like what happened to
them so that's never really gone into
but it's never it's not really you know
important to the story
and for a while I guess the reason I was
kind of curious about it was because
they don't seem at first like they're
particularly serious about legitimately
finding a fourth person to move in with
them because every single person who
responds to their ad is sort of like
ruthlessly mocked like right into their
face like they bring them into the flat
and just like start on them you
know what I mean they're or they get
like ass ridiculous and impossible
questions like stuff they can't answer
or expected to respond to these like
outrageous statements that one of the
three roommates makes
um and one candidate in particular who's
this kind of awkward Ginger hair dude
named Cameron he kind of gets the worst
of it like Alex essentially tells him
like right to his face that he's like
too much of a loser to like share air
with them and it's like he just like
just keeps brow beating him and
like that so after each after each
potential flatmate leaves kind of
dejectedly obviously because they've
just been run through the ringer
um you know the three friends just kind
of like close the door or and just like
cackle like hyenas at uh how clever they
are like you know getting rid of these
inferior specimens or whatever not too
long afterward though while Juliet is
home in the flat alone one day uh a
different sort of prospective tenant
turns up on the doorstep and this is
kind of an older kind of suave sort of
ruggedly handsome and kind of mysterious
man named Hugo now Hugo is played by a
Welsh actor named Keith Allen who fun
fact and I didn't actually know this
when I was watching the movie but is the
father of singer Lily Allen who's you
know most popular song is probably that
song you which is probably the only
one of hers that I know but uh you know
what I mean so I thought that was kind
of funny now Hugo
is a novelist or so he claims and he's
seems very sophisticated kind of like a
tough guy but also kind of like cultured
you know what I mean so Juliet is kind
of intrigued by this individual and
after he leaves she tells the other two
guys about him and Hugo then
subsequently comes over to dinner like
to meet the other two guys and they all
agree that Hugo will be a good addition
and will be allowed to move in because
he meets their High very possible
standards so so far so good uh Hugo sets
up house in the extra room and the
others kind of just go about their
normal lives or whatever
but the following day uh Hugo doesn't
come out of his room and doesn't answer
any of their knocks or anything like
that uh his car is still parked outside
in the street and nobody saw him leave
the apartment so what exactly is he
doing in there so the bedroom door is
locked uh but they kind of bust it down
only to find spoiler alert it's not
really a spoiler because this is
actually in the trailer they find a
naked Hugo sprawled out dead across the
bed uh he died they don't really go into
it but you're led to assume that it was
a drug overdose but you don't you never
find out I don't think whether it was
accidental or on purpose you know what I
mean now Juliet who is a doctor remember
uh she's you know kind of troubled but
mostly unfazed by this like oh like
you know she's just mostly annoyed I
feel like
um and Alex who's even more callous
about the he immediately starts
rifling through the dude's belongings
like to see what the deal is like you
know find out some stuff about him now
David the accountant um he's kind of
obviously the most sensitive the most
upright of the three
um and he's really the only one that
seems at all disturbed by this man's
untimely demise now during Alex's
Shakedown of Hugo's room he finds a
suitcase underneath the bed that is just
filled to the brim with cash
now David who is very proper and by the
book obviously he insists they should go
straight to the police and reasonably
argues that you know bad people might be
looking for this money because obviously
who the carries a suitcase with
cash around like nobody good that's for
sure but Juliet and Alex uh they kind of
chide him for how cowardly he is and
he's like oh you want to call the police
and tell him we found this big huge
suitcase full of money and you don't
want it it's like that's ridiculous
um so they eventually wheedle him into
keeping the money
problem with that though is that they're
gonna have to obviously get rid of the
body somehow and while these three are
fairly amoral douchebags it seems
um they presumably don't have much
experience with you know corpse disposal
or anything of that nature however they
have apparently seen a lot of uh crime
programs so they think that they can
pull this off I guess uh so Alex
actually suggests it's like I know what
we'll do we'll take the body out in the
woods
cut off his hands and kind of destroy
his teeth like you know bashing his
teeth in order to sort of like hamper
identification then they're gonna bury
him in a remote location and then dump
his car into like this deep Reservoir
that they know about and Juliet also
says oh well I can dispose of the hands
like in the hospital's incinerator
because like I said she's a doctor
so while all of this planning is going
on
um there are actually occasional
intercuts or flashbacks or whatever of
two criminals who you're led to assume
are Associates of Hugo's kind of asking
around and even torturing various people
to get information on where Hugo might
have got off to with all of that money
so you as the viewer just know that it's
only a matter of time before their paths
will cross with those of the kind of
like oblivious housemates who are just
worried about how they're going to get
rid of this body and like keep all this
money
so Juliet Alex and David they put their
plan into motion but when the time comes
you know like for the rubber to hit the
road like somebody actually has to jump
down in the grave and you know start
cutting Hugo up essentially like you
know start mutilating the body
understandably probably nobody really
wants to do it now Alex I guess was sort
of like expecting Juliet to like bite
the bullet and do it because she he
quips to her he's like hey you're a
doctor you kill people every day but
she's like well no this is different so
I can't do it so they argue back and
forth and finally it ends up that they
actually feel like draw straws to like
figure out who's gonna like mutilate
this corpse right so unfortunately the
mousey David uh gets the honors and so
there's kind of like this really cool
sequence where he's like backlit by red
so I'm assuming it's like brake lights
and stuff like that like out in the
woods at night where and he's kind of
like sawing he's in silhouette like in
the red like just sawing this body apart
right so it's it's actually like a
really cool looking sequence so now that
they have that little um obstacle out of
the way uh the housemates are seemingly
Home Free right right no not not so much
uh David thinks probably again
reasonably that they should hide the
money for a while until they can be sure
that nobody is coming to look for it but
Alex and Juliet who like I said seem
like they're kind of used to getting
their way they're very impulsive you
know they're very privileged and they're
just like what good is taking all that
cash if you can't like enjoy it right
um for a while though they do kind of
listen to David David's plan because
they understand that it's like pretty
reasonable and he actually stashes the
suitcase like up in this water tank like
up in their attic Loft kind of thing but
uh shortly after that Alex and Juliet
decide they're gonna get a little bit
greedy and they want to go like on a
ridiculous shopping spree where they
just buy a bunch of useless ridiculous
crap uh so they actually do that there's
also kind of like an amusing scene which
is sort of like put in there I guess is
like a Bellwether of what's to come
regarding like their actions eventually
gonna have consequences where Alex
actually kind of gets paid back for
being so mean to Cameron like the
red-headed guy at the beginning who came
there wanting to move in with them and
he just like you know relentlessly like
mocked him the whole entire time so that
kind of like comes to fruition later on
too like I said it's sort of like a
little side plot hinting that's like hey
you can't just go around being like that
or shit's gonna come back and bite you
in the ass now subsequently
David's mental health starts to
deteriorate because like I said he was
probably the least mentally prepared to
deal with actually having to like cut up
a body and he's like resentful that the
other two
um didn't really have to get their hands
dirty I guess so um he starts getting
like more forceful and aggressive which
at first like the other two housemates
like that because they thought like he
was too Meek before I guess but he also
starts getting a lot more paranoid as he
begins to believe uh rightly so as it
turns out that Alex and Juliet might
have kind of their own little plans for
this money um that might not necessarily
involve him so he ends up moving up into
the attic like to sort of like guard the
money he starts drilling holes in the
ceiling so he can like keep a watch on
what they're up to and also so he can
sort of low-key spy on Juliet as well
and in the midst of all these escalating
tensions between the three housemates
where they're starting to like obviously
not trust each other and betray each
other and things like that
um you also get chickens coming home to
roost in the form of Hugo's former
Associates uh and the police like who
start sniffing around and everybody
starts thinking maybe they're gonna be
in big trouble from one or the other so
I got say like for a debut feature like
a directorial debut shallow grave is an
amazingly assured film it's very very
confident
um it has like a lot of Danny Boyle's
signature style uh you know that you'll
recognize particularly from
Trainspotting and a few of his films
from the 90s
um and it's almost like fully formed
already like right out the gate you have
like the kind of kinetic editing like
especially at the beginning with like
these high-speed um kind of shots like
over the city and things like that
um you have the kind of um the voiceover
framing uh David does it in this case uh
you know you have that in Trainspotting
as well and you also have essentially
um a gang of really obnoxious and sort
of violently unlikable and yet still
compelling characters although I did see
some reviews of this where people were
like they couldn't really get behind the
movie because the characters were so
unlikable but I didn't find that the
case I don't necessarily think a
character has to be unlike or has to be
likable to be relatable or to be
compelling and I think I think the cases
even though the three of these people
are unlikable you still kind of want to
watch them anyway
now it definitely does have elements of
the Coen Brothers early work
particularly Blood Simple and um Danny
Boyle actually did acknowledge that that
was a direct influence on this film has
a little bit of like a sprinkling of
Hitchcock as well particularly like rope
or something like that
um but it's all kind of filtered through
like a 1990s British sensibility I guess
um now I will say that watching it now
because like I said it's probably been
at least 20 years since I've seen it
last time I did find some of the early
dialogue um you know where the flatmates
are because there's like a sequence
which is kind of like funny where
they're interviewing all these potential
housemates and uh and stuff like that I
did find some of that dialogue a little
try hard or a little like trying too
hard to be like Edge lordy you know
because it was the 90s and that was very
much of the time although I I'm always
like amused by the fact that one of the
potential attendants is like this goth
chick and she's sitting there on the
couch and Alex says to her it's you and
McGregor and he says here it's like when
you get up in the morning how do you
decide which shade of black to wear
which I always think very funny because
I'm like hey that's that's a thing so
don't even make fun about that but I do
find I do find some of that dialogue
like I said like trying a little bit too
hard just slightly I didn't think that
at the time but I think that now like
with with all of the uh you know ensuing
years but that's just it's very very
minor so don't like make too much out of
that but aside from that this is just
like a very dark hilarious Grim uh you
know just entertaining film overall it's
got some great performances in it like I
said very early you and McGregor are
very early Christopher Eccleston stuff
so if you like those two actors and want
to see them like in their you know early
days then this is like a good one to
watch it has like a lot of cool uh
camera work to it and really has this
very entertaining narrative that really
never lets up it's not long it doesn't
overstay its welcome or anything like
that so I kind of feel like if you
really liked Trainspotting in particular
and some of Boyle's later work and are
particularly too a fan of kind of like
stylish British crime Thrillers that
also sort of have elements of like dark
comedy to them then I would definitely
recommend shallow grave if you haven't
seen it um I feel like it's sort of a
little bit underseen if that sounds like
something that you would really be into
then yeah then you should definitely
check this out as I said as of this
recording uh it was on HBO Max I'm not
sure about I'm sure it's on other
streaming services as well but that's
where I watched it because that's
because I have that uh so yeah so check
it out um it's definitely worth watching
I think there's also a Criterion
Collection if you want to go uh you know
version if you want to go that route so
yeah I would definitely recommend it if
you're into British Cinema from the 90s
if you like those crime Thrillers that
kind of came out in you know after this
then you will probably really enjoy it
um but you know if you've seen it let me
know in the comments what you thought
about it and that will do it for this
flickers of fear I'll see you guys again
on the next one bye